depuis ce week-end les habitants des
chefs lieux de canton d'indre et loire
et du loir-et-cher doivent eux aussi se
plier au port du masque en extérieur
nouvelles restrictions imposées par les
préfectures pour freiner la propagation
de l'épidémie dans ces villes en milieu
rural où les regroupements sont rares la
mesure est diversement appliquées et
comprises exemple à château-renault
florent clavel 1 samedi sur la place
principale de chateaurenaud ça ressemble
à ça trois ados sur un banc faute de
cafés ouverts pour se retrouver pas
franchement les images des quais de
loire tourangeau et ses grappes
d'étudiants alors le port du masque
obligatoire
on n'est pas dangereux dans astro noah
lors je pense que c'est pas utile
bah quoi c'est une petite ville et si on
savait pas trop si c'était obligatoire
comme dans les grandes stars un peu plus
loin deux castes et renaudine elle déjà
habitué au port du masque en extérieur
en semaine elle travaille à tours où il
est obligatoire depuis plusieurs mois
qui dit monde ou pas on se protège nous
on protège les autres il suffit de
rencontrer justin personne n'est pas
besoin d'avoir un attroupement non plus
pour obligatoirement mettre le masque
pour faire respecter ce port du masque
la mairie communique aux entrées de
ville et sur son site internet
elle compte aussi mobilisé sa police
municipale en effet le port du masque on
soit en ville ou dans le monde rural
il faut le porter même si on se dit que
on peut être plus protégés en ruralité
mais vous voyez bien que ce n'est pas le
cas outre le port du masque la vente
d'alcool aux verts est désormais
interdite mesures qui visent à éviter
les attroupements les week end à tours
pour ce caviste qui a scrupuleusement
respecté la loi en fermant son bar à vin
cette mesure arrive bien tard c'est
gênant de savoir que les bars ont pu
continuer à travailler dans le centre de
tours alors que
alors que c'était logique on veut fermer
la consommation d'alcool sur le public a
toujours été interdite et entendre que
que des bars ont été autorisés avant
même à emporter
c'est juste je comprends pas à château
renault selon santé publique france le
taux d'incidence est aujourd'hui
supérieur à 250 cas pour 100000
habitants dans la moyenne du département